good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 3,300 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures containment of SCP 3,300 is
focused on observation and ensuring it
does not spread from the affected area a
mobile observation post has been set up
five kilometres outside of the town of
Clearwater Montana for this purpose
attempts at manned exploration of SCP
3,300 events are currently suspended
when the SCP 3,300 event begins the
observation team will fall back to a
point ten kilometers from the town
border and continue observation
any unusual activity is to be noted and
the attempts made by outsiders to enter
or exit the area will be halted
non-lethal force is authorized
for this purpose instances of scp-352
tained and interviewed under the
pretense of a police search following
this they will be allowed to continue
their travel under foundation
observation all personnel involved in
the containment of SCP 3300 are
prescribed a weekly dose of class y
amnestics description SCP 3300 is an
annual event in which the populace of
Clearwater Montana henceforth SCP 3301
disappears and is replaced by a new set
of citizens the SCP 3300 event typically
occurs in the mid portion of June and
lasts six to 18 days the first 48 hours
of each event are marked by a light
continuous rain over the entire city the
rain is stationary and appears
regardless of the weather in the
surrounding area this portion of the
event ends when the rain transitions to
a severe thunderstorm lasting for the
remaining duration of SCP 3,300 the
interior of an SCP 3300 event past this
point has never been observed any
attempt by the foundation to explore the
event has ended in either a total loss
of personnel equipment or a failure to
even enter the phenomena several times
personnel entering a CP 3300 have
emerged instantaneously on the other
side when the SCP 3,300 event ends all
previous SCP 3301 instances will have
been replaced by new iterations with
completely new appearances personalities
and memories beyond remarking on the
unusually severe nature of the storm new
instances show no recollection of the
event instances of scp-339
certain memories and brought personality
traits with those from previous
iterations of SCP 3300 however
NOAA CP 3300 one instance has been
observed repeating from previous events
SCP 3301 instances are unaware of their
anomalous nature and the circumstances
surrounding their existence physical and
post-mortem examinations reveal no
differences from baseline humans
instances of scp-323 300 occurs will
disappear several days after the event
begins
all attempts to observe this
disappearance have failed
as CP 3300 is accompanied by a moderate
kognito hazardous effect outside
citizens learning about the existence of
the town of Clearwater or its citizens
will give little thought to them unless
the subject is brought to their direct
attention this effect affects focus
rather than memory those affected do not
forget that clear water exists but
rather show difficulty paying attention
to it outside citizens familiar with
disappeared instances of scp-323 of SCP
3300 is unknown records of its existence
go back to the beginning of the
foundation despite this almost no
progress has been made in attempts to
research the phenomena addendum the
following journal was recovered in the
aftermath of the SCP 3300 event ending
on the 30th of June 1995 and represents
one of the few descriptions of what
occurs during the phenomena the writer
of the document has been identified as
SCP 3,300 1995 43078 Lane the events
described in the journal are unverified
attempts to automatically observe the
interior of an SCP 3300 event are still
underway
okay I'm gonna start reading this
document from the beginning
hey if Kurt Cobain kept their journal it
can't be that bad of an idea right
finally get all the writing I've wanted
to done
mom said it might be a good way for me
to focus things which means she just
wants an easy way to snoop and make sure
I'm staying clean joke's on her though
and if she thinks she's ever gonna be
able to find this still I guess it could
be nice to have something to look back
on hopefully to remind myself that
things get better there's a dream I've
been having which is weird because I
usually don't remember my dreams but
I've had this one like three times in
the past week in it I'm not myself I'm
in a small hut standing above the bed
where my daughter lies her skin is red
blotchy hot I praying that the disease
won't take her praying that she will
recover or this is some other sickness
it's no use I know the corpse of my
husband won't let me forget
another of the healthy that boy who
thinks himself a man calls us together
the few that remain at gaze around the
room to see the same expressions on
their faces that I feel in my heart I'll
accept the boys he grins as we enter in
gestures to the bowl of water in front
of him
I have found it he says the key to our
salvation and then it ends weird right
no idea what to make of it anyway I'm
heading to Sam's so this will be it for
the day great clouds on the horizon we
need a rain I can't remember what the
Sun looks like joking but it's been
drizzling for three days and it doesn't
look like it's gonna let up soon
phones are patchy as hell - radio says
we can expect the weather to continue
for at least a week David tried to come
home earlier today and I told him [ __ ]
right bag off to the ditch he crawled
out of that I didn't care how good the
[ __ ] he'd gotten his hands on was he did
this whole kicked puppy dog routine but
eventually left before mom noticed thank
God the rains kind of relaxing actually
it's got a rhythm to it I think you get
used to this I don't think it's ever
stormed this heart of my life it's 2:00
in the afternoon but looking outside
you'd swear it was midnight my throat's
starting to get sore from shouting over
the noise no idea what the hell happened
one minute it was drizzling the next
someone flipped a switch that dumped the
entire Pacific Ocean onto our heads
internet and phone are completely down
the few seconds of clear radio we can
get is just a barrage of tornado and
flood warnings nothing to do but hole up
inside and see how many games of
monopoly we can play until mom kills me
or I kill myself I swear some of the
people in this town must be absolutely
insane because sometimes when lightning
flashes I can see them walking around
outside some of them just standing there
I'm writing this from the back of
Jarrod's van and we're going like 80
miles an hour down the highway and
Isabelle's crying next to me I don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on I think
I'm gonna die I'm gonna keep writing
though my hand shakes less when I write
it couldn't have been more than an hour
ago that this happened we were all at my
place Sam Jared Mike and Isabel it all
came over I hadn't expected them but
Jared insisted he wasn't going to let
something tiny like a biblical flood
stop us from exploring the bottom levels
of the dread Lich arzga nots domain
stupid stupid so we rolled up and
started playing like everything was
normal
Sam DMing with a stupid little monster
accent she does Isabel and Mike arguing
over every scrap of treasure and
possible trap we came across Jared
struggling just to keep us all from
killing each other
mom in the other room pretending she
wasn't listening in it was Isabel who
first noticed the banging on the door
like someone trying to break it down at
first we were unsure what to do I mean
anyone banging that hard on your door so
late is gonna be suspicious even if
there's not a [ __ ] hurricane outside
right so we just sort of sat there
staring at each other until Jared got up
grabbed a poker from the fireplace and
went to check the people I wonder what
his first thought was surprise confusion
then he just accepted like I did do
stunned by the weirdness to question
when he opened the door and saw a family
on our porch now mom dad and two kids
I've never seen any of them before for a
second we all just stared at each other
and then the dad shoved past Jared and
said
why are you in my house mom had come out
of her room when she first heard
knocking when the guy said that she
flipped out instantly what do you mean
your house [ __ ] this is my house
what the hell are you doing just barging
in here I swear to God you've got ten
seconds before I get the cops over here
god I remember being annoyed embarrassed
wishing she wouldn't flip out over
everything the dad's expression didn't
change he stepped forward again and
Jared tried to hold him back and when he
did the dad just flung him snagged Jared
by the collar and passed him through the
living room into the kitchen
Jared smacked into a counter and went
limp and the dad said again in the exact
tone why are you in my house that was
when mom charged him with a golf club
he barely had time to react before she
swung it into his chest for a second she
looked pleased with herself I'm sure she
was already forming the story to tell
all her friends about how she fought off
the home invader when she tried to pull
the golf club back and she couldn't the
expression disappeared the guy didn't
look a bit hurt not even fazed the club
was stuck in his chest and the skin
around it was rippling like when you
throw a stone into a pond water dripped
out from where the metal entered the
skin mom stared and she screamed fell
back scrambling at the floor to get away
the man looked down at the club with the
same expression you might look at a dead
cockroach he grasped it right below her
it's Spirit into him he acted from his
chest held it as he walked towards mom
she stopped moving the first time he hit
her in the head she just fell like a
rock and he hit her again and again and
again
and the whole time he was saying my
house my house in the same [ __ ] tone
the only [ __ ] way he knew how to
speak and the kids were just standing in
the door just watching and the wife was
holding them close and I swear to god
she was smiling
Sam stood up like she was going to
charge the guy but Mike wrapped himself
around her and said don't that we had to
just run so we did Mike and Sam grabbed
Jared even though he wasn't moving and I
grabbed the journal without even
thinking about it
and I don't really remember anything
after that except Sam driving and crying
and Mike screaming and all I could think
about was the way mom's body looked as
she fell the light disappearing from her
eyes before her body hit the floor we
drove right into the police station me
and Mike decided to go inside while
Sammon Isabel watched Jared the lights
were on but the station was locked with
no one inside
we walked her out looked through every
window nothing when we got back to the
car
Jared still wasn't awake and his
breathing was all [ __ ] up so we
discussed it and decided to take him to
the hospital and land heart it's only a
two-hour drive we should be there soon
it'll be okay
who have been driving for six hours now
we're almost out of gas
Jared still isn't awake and we haven't
made it to land heart yet we've doubled
back twice look for road signs building
lights anything to tell us where the
[ __ ] we are but there's just nothing no
signs no cities not even a gas station
we haven't passed another car since we
left my house the rains falling just as
hard out here mike says we need to turn
around try to get back to town before we
get stranded Isabelle says that's crazy
we need to keep looking for the hospital
and we don't have enough money to make
it back anyway sam says she's gonna keep
driving that's all we can do at this
point
Jared's dead and we're out of gas the
car died maybe an hour ago
Jared maybe half an hour after that no
idea where we are we decided to double
back see if we had passed the hospital
again but there was nothing Isabel and
Mike are going at it
each convinced this is the others fault
Sam's ignoring them she's sitting by
Jared holding his hand she hasn't looked
away from him since he stopped breathing
hasn't said ten words since we left town
I must have fallen asleep because I had
another dream I knew instantly it was a
continuation from before it was too
clear to substantial to be anything else
and even though I knew it was a dream I
couldn't do anything but watch I stand
ankle deep in a vast clear river I'm
holding the corpse of my daughter I'm
not sure how I recognize her has taken
by the sickness as she is her hair is
falling out
her skin is entirely covered in black
scabs that hid even her eyes flecks of
cracked skin fall away as my arms rub
against her body but for some reason as
I look at her I don't feel sorrow I feel
hope
I kneel and place her body into the
water it drifts on the surface then the
water engulfs her makes her a part of it
she becomes the current that takes her
and I know it'll sweep her into the sea
where she can finally be at peace but
the work isn't done I turn Wade back to
the shore where the blackened body of my
husband waits as I do I become cognizant
of the others the survivors each has
with them the bodies of their children
families friends 18 survivors hundreds
of bodies one by one we take them to the
river until only we remain
I woke up to the sound of Jared
evaporating it took me a moment to
realize what was going on the others
were all scrambling around the body and
I couldn't get a good look all I could
see was the steam filling the car when I
pushed my way through I saw his body was
boiling that's the best way to describe
it
bubbles writhing and popping across the
surface of his skin drops of water
leaping off him and burning or they
touched us the shape of him almost
completely gone aside from a vaguely
human looking lump within his clothing
and some ridges that might have been
facial features Sam tried to touch the
water - I don't know stop it save him
catch him but the heat of the steam
pushed her back all we could do was
watch his Jared's fizzled away until the
only thing left of him was vapor and
soaked clothing we decided to leave or
Mike and Sam decided to leave and
Isabelle and I realized we didn't have
any choice but to follow I mean what
difference did it make
stay or go the outcome would have been
the same but I figured trying to find
something out there might be better than
staying in a car until we all starve to
death we grabbed a flashlight from the
glove box and headed out
we couldn't have walked more than a mile
before we reached the town I almost
bumped into Mike when he stopped walking
after shining the light onto the welcome
to Clearwater sign he didn't say
anything what could he say we turned
around started walking the other way not
sure how far two miles three we didn't
pass the car but it didn't matter we
ended up back at the sign the city Sam
turned walked off the highway and into
the farmland surrounding it
we followed we knew it wouldn't work but
we followed anyway on the other side of
the field we found ourselves back on the
highway in front of the sign Mike
insisted he wasn't going back in no
[ __ ] way he'd rather take the risk
out in the rain than spend another
second with whatever was in that city we
pointed out that whatever was in the
city was pretty clearly outside of it
too and at least the city had food he
wouldn't listen so we started walking in
three minutes later he caught up didn't
say a word the lights in the town were
all on but there were no people no cars
a few times I thought I saw movement but
it was always just a branch or a piece
of trash picked up by the wind we were
on alert the whole time but nothing
happened we decided to hole up in Dirk's
sporting because it had guns and it was
right next to the grocery store Sam and
Mike went to grab food while Isabel and
I meaning just I took stock of the store
when the others came back we started
working out shifts to sleep in to awake
at the same time I volunteered for the
first shift even though I felt like I
wanted to collapse I just couldn't stand
to dream again Mike shot himself
and were a lot more [ __ ] than I first
thought for a while I was holding on to
the idea of survival that there was some
sort of exit to whatever fucked-up
situation we found ourselves in there
isn't I don't think there ever was this
is the only ending I could have hoped
for but if I keep thinking about that
I'm gonna go [ __ ] insane so Mike he's
dead we were on shift together when he
got up and said he'd be back in a minute
figured he was just going to the
bathroom until I heard a gunshot I got
there about 20 seconds before salmon is
ago his body slumped against the wall
shotgun barrels stuck in his mouth there
was no blood and I thought he'd missed
or accidentally discharged it until I
saw the hole in the back of his skull
then I realized there was something
splattered on the wall behind him but it
wasn't blood it was water Isobel
screamed when she saw the body
I heard her grasping and ignored her Sam
knelt next to me close enough that I
could feel her trembling for a moment
the only noise was her ragged breathing
in Isabelle's whimpers then Sam reached
out and ran her fingers along the rim of
Mike's skull she drew them back stared a
small noise from the back of her throat
her fingertips were coated in water
before I could react she thrust more
fingers into the wound
water ran down her hands as she dug
through what should have been his brain
water sloshed in the chalice of his
skull when we lowered his body to rest
on the floor it was water that pooled on
the wood
Sam leaped up ran to the counter
snatched a knife from its sheath and
held it to her arm we stared at each
other I didn't want her to do it I
didn't want to see what would happen she
sliced open her arm and water spilled
from the wound we stared at the injury
to distract it to notice is about
calling to us it wasn't until she ran
over and yanked on my sleeve that I
remembered she existed outside was all
she said hundreds of people had gathered
outside the window on moving silhouettes
staring through the darkness filling the
street when lightning flashed I saw the
faces of strangers soaked by the rain
they've been here for two hours now
haven't moved an inch they're outside
every window every exit I don't know how
long they're willing to wait but I'm
damn sure as longer than we have maybe
Mike had the right idea Sam left and we
didn't bother to stop her she muttered
something before she stood and marched
out of the door I remember thinking as I
watched her leave that I should do
something I should reach out or call to
her block her exit but the thought
wouldn't make it past my brain like
there was a small wall between my nerves
in my body so I just stared as she
stepped into the rain
the silhouette shifted as soon as she
was outside they opened up to let her
through
and she vanished into them
into the dark I don't want to go back
that's what she said before she left in
my dream I am the storm and I'm
screaming the wind whips at me like
razors raking through my body the frozen
rain bites at my skin except I don't
have a body and I don't have skin the
wind is part of me
the rain is from me every second I rip
myself apart and reform rip and reshape
until I am scattered over miles of storm
trapped in the royal around me I hear
screams of my village I feel their
presence against mine
just as much a part of the storm as I we
fight struggle but the storm cannot be
broken it hurdles over the land dragging
us in its wake and then I'm falling
rushing to meet the ground for a moment
the earth embraces me I remember what it
felt like to feel the dirt beneath my
feet and the Sun on my skin and the
crisp air in my lungs until the storm
steals me again and I am pulled back
into the screams of my comrades I woke
up and Isabel was gone just a puddle of
water on the floor I think the rain is
speaking to me I can hear it ever since
I woke up I don't know what it's saying
but the whispers in my ear are getting
louder when I cover my ears it's still
there if I scream it rises over the
screaming I'm trying to write just to
focus on anything else but the [ __ ]
voice is still there and I don't know
what it wants me to do it wants me to
join it
I'm its child and it misses me it can't
bear to be apart what can I do what can
I do the strangers are still outside
watching me waiting for my choice
because they know what my choice will be
don't they there's only one way this can
end I can wait
and starve or shoot myself or slit my
wrists or walk out into the rain because
it's all going to end the same way the
water is eternal the water will remain
no matter how polluted it becomes at the
end we all become rain I don't want to
go back
anyway on that very unsettling and
creepy note I'm gonna leave this lecture
here thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Jim's Saba Maximus Decimus arbiter
Sewell dr. bright Darius Tom Justin de
turn armed agents Nider Joker Corvis and
jayvo Jack Corey Barker and Arun Ian
thank you all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
you